what we're going to do in this video is
calculate by hand to correlation
coefficient for a set of bivariate data
and when I say bivariate it's just a
fancy way of saying for each X data
point there is a corresponding Y data
point
now before I calculate the correlation
coefficient let's just make sure we
understand some of these other
statistics that they've given us so we
assume that these are samples of the X
and the corresponding Y from a broader
population and so we have the sample
mean for X and the sample standard
deviation for X the sample mean for X is
quite straightforward to calculate it
would just be 1 plus 2 plus 2 plus 3
over 4 and this is 8 over 4 which is
indeed equal to 2 the sample standard
deviation for X we've also seen this
before this should be a little bit
review it's going to be the square root
of the distance from each of these
points to the sample mean squared so 1
minus 2 squared plus 2 minus 2 squared
plus 2 minus 2 squared plus 3 minus 2
squared all of that over since we're
talking about sample standard deviation
it's we have four data points so one one
less than four is all of that over three
now this actually simplifies quite
nicely because this is 0 this is 0 this
is 1 this is 1 and so you essentially
get the square root of 2/3 which is if
you approximate 0.8 1 6 so that's that
and the same thing is true for Y the
sample mean for Y if you just add up 1
plus 2 Plus 3 plus 6 over 4 for data
points this is 12 over 4 which is indeed
equal to 3 and then the sample standard
deviation for y you would calculate the
exact same way we did it for X and you
get 2 point 1 6 0 now with all of that
out of the way let's think about how we
calculate the correlation coefficient
now right over here is
a representation for the formula for the
correlation coefficient at first it
might seem a little intimidating until
you realize a few things all this is
saying is for each corresponding x and y
find the z-score for x so we could call
this Z sub X for that particular X so Z
sub X sub I and we could say this is the
z-score for that particular Y Z sub y
sub I is one way that you could think
about it look this is just saying for
each data point find the difference
between it and its mean and then divide
by the standard the sample standard
deviation and so that's how many sample
standard deviations is it away from its
mean and so that's the z-score for that
X data point and this is the z-score for
the corresponding Y data point
how many sample standard deviations is
it away from the sample mean in the real
world you won't have only four pairs and
it will be very hard to do it by hand
and we typically use software computer
tools to do it but it's really valuable
to do it by hand to get an intuitive
understanding of what's going on here so
in this particular situation R is going
to be equal to one over N minus one we
have four pairs so it's going to be one
over three and it's going to be times a
sum of the products of the Z scores so
this first pair right over here
so this the z-score for this one is
going to be one minus how far it is away
from the X sample mean divided by the X
sample standard deviation zero point
eight one six that times one now we're
looking at the Y variable the Y z-score
so it's 1 minus 3 1 minus 3 over the Y
sample standard deviation 2 point 1 6 oh
and we're just going to keep doing that
I'll do it like this so the next one
it's going to be 2 minus 2 over 0 point
8 1 6 that is where I got the 2 from and
I'm
subtracting from that the sample mean
right over here times now we're looking
at this two to minus three over two
point one six zero plus I'm happy
there's only four pairs here 2 minus 2
again 2 minus 2 over zero point eight
one six times now we're going to have 3
minus 3 3 minus 3 over two point one six
zero and then the last pair you're going
to have 3 minus 2 3 minus 2 over 0 point
8 1 6 times 6 minus 3 6 minus 3 over 2
point 1 6 0 so before I get a calculator
out let's see if there are some
simplifications I can do 2 minus 2
that's going to be 0 0 times anything is
0 so this whole thing is 0 2 minus 2 is
0 3 minus 3 is going to actually be 0
times 0 so that whole thing is 0 let's
see this is going to be 1 minus 2 which
is negative 1 1 minus 3 is negative 2 so
this is going to be R is equal to 1/3
times negative times negative is
positive and so this is going to be 2
over zero point eight one six times two
point one six zero and then plus 3 minus
2 is 1 6 minus 3 is 3 so plus 3 over
zero point eight one six times two point
one six zero well these are the same
denominator so actually I could rewrite
if I have 2 over this thing plus three
over this thing that's going to be 5
over this thing so I could rewrite this
whole thing five over zero point eight
one six times two point one six zero and
now I can just get a calculator out to
actually calculate this so we have 1
divided by 3 times 5 divided by zero
point eight one six times two point one
6:0 won't make a difference but I'll
just write it down and then I will close
that parenthesis and let's see what we
get we get an R of and since everything
else goes to the thousands place I'll
just round to the thousands place an R
of 0.9 for six so R is approximately
zero point nine four six so what does
this tell us the correlation coefficient
is a measure of how well a line can
describe the relationship between x and
y r is always going to be greater than
or equal to negative one and less than
or equal to 1 if R is positive 1 it
means that an upward sloping line can
completely describe the relationship if
R is negative 1 it means a downward
sloping line can completely describe the
relationship are anywhere in between
says well it won't just it won't be as
good if R is 0 that means that a line
isn't describing the relationships well
at all now in our situation here not to
use a pun in our situation here our R is
pretty close to 1 which means that a
line can get pretty close to describing
the relationship between our exes and
our Y's so for example I'm just going to
try to hand draw a line here and it does
turn out that our least squares line
will always go through the mean of the x
and the y so the mean of the X is to
mean of the Y is 3 we'll study that in
more depth in future videos but let's
see this actually does look like a
pretty good line so let me just draw it
right over there you see that I actually
can draw a line that gets pretty close
to describing it isn't perfect if it
went through every point then I would
have an R of 1 but it gets pretty close
to describing what is going on now the
next thing I want to do is focus on the
intuition what was actually going on
here with these z-scores and how do you
how does taking products of
corresponding z-scores get
this property that I just talked about
where an R of one will be strong
positive correlation R of negative one
would be strong negative correlation
well let's draw the sample means here so
the X sample mean is 2 this is our x
axis here this is x equals 2 and our y
sample mean is 3 this is the line y is
equal to 3 now we can also draw the
standard deviations this is let's see
the standard deviation for X is zero
point eight one six so I'll be
approximating it so if I go Oh point
eight one six less than our mean it'll
get us someplace around there so that's
one standard deviation below the mean
one standard deviation above the mean
would put us someplace right over here
and if I do the same thing in Y one
standard deviation above the mean two
point one six zero so that would be five
point one six zero so it would put us
someplace around there and one standard
deviation below the mean so let's see
we're going to go if we took away two we
would go to one and then we're going to
go take another point one six zero so
it's going to be someplace right around
here so for example for this first pair
1 comma 1 what were we doing well we
said all right how many standard
deviations is this below the mean and
that turns out to be negative one over
zero point eight one six that's what we
have right over here that's what this
would have calculated and then how many
standard deviations four in the Y
direction and that is our negative two
over two point one six zero but notice
since both of them were negative it
contributed to the R this would become a
positive value and so one way to think
about it it might be helping us get
closer to the one if both of them have a
negative z-score that means that there
is a positive correlation between the
variables when one is below the mean
the other is you could say similarly
below the mean now if we go to the next
data point two comma two right over here
what happened well the X variable was
right on the mean and because of that
that entire term became zero the X
z-score was zero and so that would have
taken away a little bit from our
correlation coefficient the reason why
it would take away even though it's not
negative you're not contributing to the
sum but you're going to be dividing by a
slightly higher value by including that
extra pair if you had a data point where
let's say X was below the mean and why
was above the mean something like this
the turn if this was one of the point
this term would have been negative
because the Y z-score would have been
positive and the XD score would have
been negative and so when you put it in
the sum it would have actually taken
away from the sum and so would have made
the our score even lower
similarly something like this would have
done would have made the our score even
lower because you would have a positive
z-score for x and a negative z-score for
y and so a product of a positive and a
negative would be a negative